at seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
a national emergency and warning
people's lives could be at risk as the
uk braces for its hottest day ever
preparing for the worst hospitals rail
services roads and schools are all
expected to be hit by the impact of the
heatwave
i'm live in central london where teams
of charity workers will be helping rough
sleepers with shelter water and sun
cream to protect them from the soaring
temperatures
meanwhile wildfires are spreading across
countries in europe with record
temperatures causing loss of life and
forcing many to leave their homes to the
mercy of the flames
the race for number 10 the final five
tory leadership candidates face off
against each other honesty trust and
taxes dominate the first of the tv
debates
liz we have to be honest
we have to be honest but borrowing your
way out of inflation isn't a plan it's a
fairy tale
as covered numbers rise the drive to
reach the 3 million people in the uk who
still have not been vaccinated
a fist bump in public but in private
president biden says he told saudi
arabia's crown prince he was responsible
for the murder of journalist shamal
khashoggi
i'm in sri lanka's capital colombo where
parliament has met to start the process
of electing a new president for this
desperate and bankrupt country
in sport england's euros momentum
continues as the lionesses make it three
wins from three against northern ireland
and it's quartered to eight we'll take a
look at the papers with the editor of
spike tom slater and dawn nissim the
film editor of the daily star
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast the uk is preparing for the
hottest weather it has ever faced with
temperatures that could reach 40 degrees
celsius for the very first time a
national emergency has been declared
with a warning that people's lives could
be at risk as temperatures soar into
early next week the government says it
will continue to work closely with the
nhs and other sectors through the
weekend
on monday and tuesday the uk will be at
a red heat warning and level 4 health
warning which means the heat wave is
considered a national emergency the nhs
is now preparing for an influx of
patients as the heat could cause illness
and even death among the fit and healthy
but the greatest concern is for the
vulnerable with people being urged to
check now that relatives and neighbors
are prepared rail customers are being
advised to only travel if absolutely
essential as restrictions to protect
safety will cause delays and
cancellations on the roads more
breakdowns are expected especially for
those with older cars and drivers are
being advised to avoid journeys at the
hottest times of the day
meanwhile some schools are considering
closing for the days at the peak of the
heat wave with others taking measures
such as closing early or relaxing
uniform policies to help students cope
with the heat
we can get more in this now with our
weather presenter kirsty mccabe good
morning to you question what exactly is
causing this heat
good morning the hot weather is coming
all the way from north africa from the
sahara it's been it's this perfect storm
really a setup where high pressure is in
the right place to allow the winds to be
driven up from the south and that very
hot air has traveled all the way across
spain portugal france and now towards
the uk and the heat's going to build
through the weekend now you may already
be aware that we've had some really high
temperatures across parts of western
europe and wildfires as well and
worryingly now the hot air is heading
our way
and it is going to be really a case of
watching the numbers rise over the
coming days we're looking around maybe
28 or 29 today and then we head into the
30s through tomorrow could peak around
33 but it's monday and tuesday where we
have this extreme heat warning force a
red
extreme heat warning and that's because
we're looking at seeing temperatures
possibly breaking the record there's an
80 chance so that's pretty likely that
we're going to exceed that 38.7 record
set in 2019 and there's a 50 chance that
we can see temperatures for the first
time ever in the uk hit 40 degrees and i
know i hear a lot of people talking
about men i remember back in 1976 if i
had a penny or a pound for every time
somebody said i remember back in 1976
well i probably wouldn't be up so early
in the morning but what i have to say is
it's very different to then it is
exceptionally hot spell of weather and
we're taking it seriously because it
really heat can be deadly can be fatal
the impacts are quite wide it puts a lot
of stress on the body because we're not
just talking about high temperatures by
day we're talking about high
temperatures by night we talk about
tropical nights where temperatures don't
drop below 20 degrees all night and
that's really uncomfortable to sleep in
so we're talking about the stress in the
human body and then also just the
impacts on infrastructure and in terms
of like rail in terms of power at home
you might struggle with as well power
cuts and there's also concern for people
trying to cool off in the heat then
there's water safety incidents as well
you've got the cold water can shock the
body and then also just dangers as well
if you're jumping into a quarry lake or
whatever it's these things are all
really crucial and we will hear more
about that in the coming days as the
heat builds so it's important to be
aware i know i sound like i'm maybe
nagging on about the heat and we all do
like a summer day but this is more than
summer is exceptionally extremely hot
and we've not seen temperatures this
high ever in the uk so we are quite
concerned about the temperatures from
monday and tuesday and the heat isn't
just going to affect a small part of the
uk we've got amber warnings extending
right across england wales even into
southern scotland as well so over the
coming days we'll see the temperatures
really begin to rise and initially it is
going to be quite a dry heat and it is a
fairly short spell so choosing to
wednesday we'll start to see the
humidity build
that'll really be quite uncomfortable
and then things likely to end with a
thundery breakdown but it's worth being
aware and taking precautions i know for
myself and my children's school taking
up and taking care next week because
it's dangerous to the young and the
elderly but just anyone could be
affected by such high levels of
temperatures
okay kirsty thank you so much
well one group of people likely to be
vulnerable during the coming extreme
temperatures are the homeless the mayor
of london sadiq khan says emergency
measures have now been put in place to
help
this year for the first time we've
issued a severe weather emergency
response in summer normally we do this
in winter when it gets really cold and
it's dangerous for people to be sleeping
out in the cold weathers what we've done
this year working with excellent
councils and charities
is issued a severe weather emergency
response now
our correspondent matthew thompson joins
me now from mungo's homeless shelter in
central london how are they getting
ready there matthew
will you join me from the mainframe of
st mungo's homelessness charity in
westminster in central london and it's
from here from this nerve center if you
like that teams of specialists will be
going out all over the capital to
provide whatever help and assistance
they can to
largely rough sleepers in fact i've been
told they've had 19 referrals just in
this borough alone overnight for people
who are potentially vulnerable because
of these temperatures and that work will
only be stepping up as we head into
monday and tuesday now we're joined now
uh by one of the members of staff here
at mungus to tell us a little bit about
the work that you're actually doing so
could you explain for us
exactly why homeless particularly rough
sleepers are so vulnerable and what it
is that you guys can do about it in the
short term sure so for as i said one
goes rough sleeping is always dangerous
but in this kind of extreme weather it's
particularly dangerous there's no
shelter people don't have access to sun
cream water and for the most honourable
most people have underlying health
conditions anyway so they're even more
at risk so for us at semongo's we're
kind of going out doing extra shifts
targeting most vulnerable trying to get
them into accommodation offering sun
cream water and just checking in with
people really making sure they
understand the risk of being in the sun
all day and i mentioned referrals that
you guys have had in already how can the
members of the public anyone watching
this night how can they get in touch
with if they've got concerns about
someone who can play a really key part
in this there's an app called street
link you can google it where members of
the public and um
homeless people themselves can log where
they're rough sleeping and then our
outreach teams will get that kind of
notification go looking for those people
so it's a really key role they can play
in that
excellent thank you ever so much so as
you mentioned homelessness is just one
part of a much bigger picture there are
clearly concerns about all aspects of
british life as we head into these
record temperatures on monday and
tuesday we've had warnings from the uk
health security agency a national
emergency the first time that's happened
the met office its first ever red heat
warning that means that they're going to
be concerns about transport trains
running late tarmac can melt in these
sorts of temperatures huge pressure on
the nhs
potentially ambulances being told we
understand to limit the amount of time
they keep people waiting outside
bringing more people into cooled areas
and hospitals education as well schools
potentially going to have to close if
classrooms get too hot a number of them
already saying that they're going to
have to bring in non-uniform days so
kids can stay cool so there's lots of
ways in which we're going to be affected
the advice broadly speaking is try not
to travel if you can avoid it and pay
full attention to all the advice that
you get from the emergency services and
from the government
okay matthew thank you very much
well the hot weather is also proving
problematic across europe with the eu
urging member states to prepare for
wildfires throughout the summer in
portugal firefighters have worked
alongside local residents in an attempt
to save their homes and communities from
those rapidly spreading fires so far
across the country over 30 000 hectares
of land have been burnt
in croatia firefighters have managed to
stop flames from reaching the tourist
hotspot of odise however several
settlements and small villages in the
surrounding area have already been
evacuated
meanwhile wildfires have also forced the
evacuation of more than 11 000 people
from the bordeaux region of france high
temperatures and strong winds mean
testing conditions for the thousands of
firefighters deployed to tackle the
fires
well the former chancellor sunak remains
the front runner among fellow
conservative mps and one of those who's
throwing their weight behind him is
claire coutinho mr dino thanks so much
for joining us this morning um so how do
you think you did i thought he did very
well to be honest i mean he had one of
the hardest messages that he was saying
to people he wanted to be very honest
about what was happening in the economy
uh but really i think that rishi sinak
was the person who looked like he was
the one who could be prime minister in a
few weeks he had an incredibly
impressive command of the detail he also
i thought had a clear plan for the
future and particularly to deal with
inflation which i think is our number
one problem at the moment and most
importantly i think he was the one who
wanted to be honest with people and say
these are the challenges are ahead and
this is what we need to do to fix them
why couldn't he answer the question it
was a yes or no question about boris
johnson's honesty well i think he did
answer that question he said that when
he resigned honesty and trust uh was
part of that um and i think you know the
truth is that for all mps we will feel
that you know boris johnson for a lot of
people was the person who delivered
brexit i think for a lot of people in
the country that was a ability to
deliver something that was uh part of
their connection to him and obviously in
the last few months there have been
other challenges and things which have
happened which meant have meant other
people have felt that he he's not honest
so it's not i think very easy to have
black and white answers to these um
questions but the truth is a number of
people resigned from government last
week and rishi sunet was one of them
but he couldn't say boris johnson was
honest so do you think
he's honest
about that and
why couldn't he just say no to that
question if that's what he thinks well i
think he was very honest about that he
talked about the fact that he resigned i
think resigning was a principled
position he set out exactly why he did
that in his letter and as
i've explained and rishi has said in
this campaign i don't think anyone
should completely denigrate what boris
johnson has done over the last couple of
years he did deliver brexit um he did
very well with the things like the the
vaccine rollout
i don't think it's right to completely
trash someone's reputation but at the
same time when honesty and trust and
politics had become a challenge he did
take that difficult decision and he did
resign and actually one of the central
tenets of his campaign at the moment is
to restore trust
so
as you're saying his pitch is clearly
about being honest about the challenges
right that we face but do you think he
needs something a bit more optimistic to
win with the members don't they want
some a big britain idea or big britain
ideas to really resonate with the
members
well i mean firstly i don't think that
the members are that different from the
british public i think what people want
is a politician who will tell them the
facts as they are and who also has a
realistic plan to deal with the
challenges that are ahead i don't think
anyone that i speak to and i speak to
lots of my constituents all of the time
is thinking that this isn't a difficult
time for the country everyone can see
what inflation is doing to their income
everyone can feel the pinch and actually
what they want is someone who can
explain to them what is happening and
what their plan is to make sure that
inflation doesn't get out of control and
that is that's exactly what rishi is
doing and to be honest i thought he was
one of the only people he was doing that
last night and i think that's why people
responded to him it wasn't the easiest
message there on that stage but he
talked about not wanting to um you know
create fairy tales he talked about
wanting to be honest about what the
situation was and actually i thought
people responded to that very well
did they did they respond to him because
his polling with members is dire
well i don't actually think that you can
look at every single poll when i've
talked to members people are very
positive about him um they see him as a
very trusted decent person he's clearly
you know very intelligent he's got great
command of detail and if you look at
some of the things that he's done over
the last couple of years things like the
furlough scheme things like the cost of
living package i think you can see what
kind of politician he is
so you wouldn't be concerned then if he
was up against penny morton if you say
we shouldn't look at the polls well i
mean he talked last night and i agree
with this um that i think it's quite
commendable for the tory party to have
so many great candidates in the race uh
i think he'd welcome whoever he was up
against to have that that debate in the
final two
um well i'm not going to get into who
should be in the final two because i
think they are all good candidates i
just think that rishi sunk is the best
candidate and i think if you uh watch
the debate last night i would urge
everyone to go and watch that debate i
think it is good that we have these
robust debates about um the economy and
about the future of the country but i
thought he really did stand out heads
and shoulder as the person who had the
clearest plan and i think that's what
will come out no matter who is the other
person that he's up against
okay claire coutinho thank you so much
for talking to us thank you
let's go straight to political
correspondent rob powell he's in downing
street for us this morning so rob what
did you make of that
i think there weren't necessarily uh the
big sort of game changers that we always
look for in these debates for any of the
candidates that said i don't think
anyone completely bombed either
in terms of rishi sunak um i think his
team will be pleased with that
performance last night in terms of his
defense of his record um in the treasury
his defense of his approach to the
economy as well that said and you were
touching on this with claire coutinho
just then this is almost the most
straightforward part of the contest for
rishi sunak um i think after last night
you would expect him to be on
the ballot for the membership it's when
it goes to the members that this becomes
a lot more complex because as you were
pointing out to claire coutinho um
actually the head-to-head polling
between bishi sunak and people like liz
trust and penny mordent among the
members at the moment doesn't look good
for him so i think over the summer if he
is to make it on to those final two
that ballot paper rishi sunat will need
to do something to bring the members on
side in terms of liz trust
obviously on the economy on tax a
completely different pitch to rishi
sunak
talking more about tax cuts and the
challenge for liz trust will be
convincing people that she can do it
that these tax cuts are sustainable
and that she can push them through in a
responsible way i thought under grilling
from rishi sunak maybe more than the
presenter last night the jury is still
out
on whether she can sell that as
believable
on penny mordant i thought there are
still difficulties there on nailing down
exactly what she believes in
and bluntly if she is any good what her
record in government is and i thought on
lots of issues last night where there
was quite a big divide between
candidates especially richard zunak and
liz trust penny morning was sort of
somewhere in the middle but was
struggling to articulate exactly what um
her position was so i think that will be
the challenge for her and her team in
the coming days in terms of the outside
candidates if you like um kemi badanok
and tom tugan hat i don't think there
was anything there to suggest any major
upsets i don't think kemmie baidnock had
the breakthrough she was maybe looking
for tom tugan hat came out top in some
of the snap polling and i think did get
some of the biggest rounds of applause
of the evening potentially because he is
a lot freer in what he can say so i
think for those two candidates i don't
think anything's changed i don't think
they're going to be the next prime
minister but i think after those
performances last night they probably
haven't done themselves any harm in
getting a good job in the next
government
okay rob thank you so much
just a reminder we've got a special
program coming up next week sky news
will broadcast a live tv debate with
those who want to be the next leader of
the conservative party and the country's
next prime minister the debate between
the candidates will take place next
tuesday at 8 pm
now to sri lanka where mass protests
over the economic collapse of the
country have forced the president to
flee and resign today parliament met to
start the process of electing the
country's next president any candidates
will then be voted on next thursday
speak to correspondent nicole johnson
who is live in sri lanka's capital
colombo so nicole they started the
process of electing their next president
yes it was a short meeting of parliament
there was special meeting only 30
minutes long the nominations have opened
they'll close on tuesday and on
wednesday the parliament will elect a
new president and that will usher in a
new era effectively in sri lankan
politics because we've had the downfall
of the rajapaksa family this isn't the
end of it though for protesters far from
it they'll be keeping an eye to see who
nominates for the position of president
and they're concerned that the acting
president and former prime minister
remember wik remisinger will apply for
that job that is not acceptable for them
they regard him as a loyalist of the
rajapaksas and if he does apply for the
job we would expect to see more protests
on the street
and if in fact he does
apply for it and become president those
protests could turn violent so all eyes
in sri lanka are
are on what happens
on wednesday in that parliamentary
election for the president at the same
time though the economic situation here
is just as bad as ever the roger pax has
burned through the country's foreign
reserves
severe economic mismanagement have meant
that there's no money left to buy basic
supplies like food
fuel and medicine and what we've seen
here in sri lanka is a spectacular fall
of a middle-income country that's now
effectively bankrupt
nicole thank you very much
president joe biden met with saudi
arabia's crown prince mohammed bin
salman for the first time yesterday the
pair fist bumped upon mr biden's arrival
in jeddah for talks to reset relations
between their two countries while a
presidential candidate in 2020 joe biden
called saudi arabia a pariah over human
rights abuses particularly the murder of
the journalist jamal khashoggi in 2018.
speaking after two hours of meetings
president biden said that he told the
crown prince that he thought mohamed bin
salman was directly responsible for the
murder of khashoggi
he basically said that he
he was not personally responsible for it
i indicated i thought he was he said he
was not personally responsible for it
and he took action against those who
were responsible
three people have died and a further 15
have been injured following russian
missile attacks on the ukrainian city of
nepro the local governor says rockets
hit an industrial plant and nearby
street late last night elsewhere
ukrainian officials say at least 10
explosions have taken place in the
southern city of mikolai of overnight
russia has been accused of hitting a
university in the attack part of the
kremlin's continuing long-range
bombardment of ukraine
one of mexico's top drug lords has been
captured in an operation organized by
law enforcement agencies in the mexican
navy rafael caro quintero has been a
target for mexican and u.s officials
since he rose to power in the 1980s he
now faces extradition to the u.s and
charges there connected to the killing
of drugs enforcement agents
meanwhile the mexican navy says 14
service personnel were killed when a
black hawk helicopter crashed while it
was supporting the operation to arrest
caracon quintinero the mexican president
says the exact reason for the crash is
being investigated
look at this a pilot had a miraculous
escape as his light aircraft made a
crash landing in bruges in which he was
able to deploy a parachute system as he
fell it meant the whole plane floated
gently to earth and the pilot managed to
walk away with only
minor injuries
time for the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the heat will build this weekend with
the risk of dangerous and
record-breaking temperatures early next
week most places will have a fine and
dry start today with temperatures soon
rising in the sunshine however the far
north of scotland will be cloudy with
patchy rain away from the cloudier and
wetter north everywhere else will be dry
with plenty of sunshine hazy at times
temperatures will peak at about 26 to 29
degrees celsius in the south they will
be cooler around the coasts which of
course have the sea breeze
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
now the tory leadership debates are an
on opportunity excuse me not just for
conservative mps and the public to size
up the candidates it also offers labor
and insight into who they may be facing
over the dispatch box labour's shadow
exchequer secretary ebene oppong asari
joins me now thank you so much for
talking to us this morning so what did
you make of that debate last night
good morning sophie thanks for having me
on your show
um i have to be honest um i know that
the tories are looking at their new
leadership um cancer in terms of who's
going to take over the leader of the
party but it doesn't really make any
difference for the average person up and
down the country
all of them have been somewhat involved
in propping up the
prime minister boris johnson
throughout his failures the reality is
we've had this government for 12 years
and things haven't got any better from
people for people and i just think it's
a distraction from the issues that are
affecting people we're seeing things
such as a cost of living crisis
powerpoint delays
um there's so many things the country
isn't is in a massive crisis
and there's deletion
they need a new leader
you don't think this these debates the
leadership contest affects people up and
down the country
i think what we need to see is we need
to have a labor government and you know
because this conservative government has
consistently failed for the last 12
years and you know changing the leader
doesn't change the fact that they still
have these policies that are hurting
people what we're seeing is a leadership
contest which is pandering and focusing
on tory members which is massively out
of touch with the whole of the country
and that's why i think it's important
that you know we need a labor government
and we need the election to make it fair
so people have the choice the decision
to decide who they want to represent
them okay but as it stands now
one of the five are going to be elected
as the head of the tories i mean of
from what you saw last night
who do you think
you would have a chance up against
at a general election
i have to say from what i saw last last
night none of them impressed me i've
seen what i've seen is um tory
candidates essentially trying to
distance themselves from boris johnson
you know we're in the middle of the cost
of living crisis the majority of them
voted against labour's proposal for
windfall tax not just once not just
twice not just three times and now
they're saying that things need to
change yet they could have used the
power their positions within their roles
to kind of stop things from escalating
and they did none of that all of a
sudden so they're going to introduce
apart from um rishi sonic they all say
that they they acknowledge that there is
this huge cost of living crisis these
are the candidates right they
acknowledge this that there is a huge
cost of living crisis and they've all
come up with ideas on how they're going
to tackle them
the majority of them say they're going
to cut taxes rishi sonic says that he's
called it a fairy tale but so it does
look as if they are engaging with the
issues and they do recognize the issues
i mean this is far too late we've seen
15 tax files of 15 taxes implemented in
the last two years we're the only g7
country that's implemented attacks in
the middle of the cost of living crisis
when labor was five weeks
in five weeks we'll have a new head of
the
head of the tories and um de facto head
of
prime minister excuse me and four out of
the five say they are going to cut taxes
the devil's in the detail i've seen
these promises made by these
conservative government before and
conserve some of those conservative
candidates and nothing's materialized
you know we would need to see what's
going to happen but what i'm seeing is a
lot of things being promised a lot of
things being promised in terms of how
there's going to be low taxes but
there's no real plan in terms of how
that's going to be addressed and i think
it's really important if you get the
opportunity to to kind of question them
and how this would realistically be
delivered
okay so if they did come up against kia
stammer a lot of people say he just
doesn't have the charisma to carry labor
through a general election and to
actually win
i fundamentally disagree with that um i
think that kierstalmer is is showing
leadership in terms of where the
government hasn't been
i think how is he doing that
well what we've seen is the government
has been distracted by internal far
internal fighting the conservatives
they've been distracted by the fact that
what is doing to show leadership well
kirsten has been having conversations
with people up and down the country has
been showing a real alternative in terms
of leadership in terms of how labour
would do things differently he has
consistently said that the government
needs to have a clear plan to address
the fact that the economy isn't growing
and has provided recommendations in
terms of how to do this you know we've
seen things being implemented by the
government in terms of the fact that
national insurance contributions have
been increased in the middle cost of
living crisis and i have to say i find
it quite baffling that last night some
of the candidates were saying that now
they're going to remove it yet the fact
that when we consistently raise actually
shouldn't be done they wouldn't listen
is it because
so what would you do to deal with the
cost of living crisis
um i think we've been we've made this
position very clear so what we've said
is that we need to look at the economy
in terms of how to grow properly
we've said that the national insurance
contributions increase in national
insurance contributors now is not the
time to be delivering this we need the
government to also address the fact that
this
winter things are going to get a lot
worse in terms of energy bills that are
going to be increasing and we've looked
at how there needs to be a long-term
plan to address the energy crisis
a lot of the things that we have
recommended in terms of coming from
labour i have to say they have been
later imitated by the conservatives
because it's quite clear they're running
out of steam they've got no plans and
we're leading in those areas and they're
following on the issues that goes in
okay thank you so much for talking to us
thank you
still to come on sky news breakfast
we'll have a look at some of the stories
making this morning's papers tom slater
the editor of spike and the former
editor of the daily star dawn nissan
will be back again with us
[Music]
hello again we're gonna have another
look through the papers with us this
morning to do so editor of spike tom
slater and dawn nissin the former editor
of the daily star tom and dawn hello
again to you both let's start with uh
something a bit more cheerful than the
heatwave no not really the travel chaos
what's this story in um is it telegraph
tom
yes so this is a story about how
essentially more travel chaos um for
people trying to get their summer
holidays off the ground so airport
bosses at heathrow
excuse me have urged various carriers to
essentially boot a number of people off
of flights to allow them to leave so
that is rather than cancelling whole
flights in relation to the staff
shortages particularly in ground staff
we're just
to put a cap on the number of people who
are allowed to get on those flights to
try and ease some of the congestion um
this is something that they've tried
before usually limiting it to about 75
to 80 percent but you know more bad news
for people who with the restrictions
lifting and with us easing ourselves out
of the pandemic we're all looking
forward to a good restriction-free
summer but we're seeing all of these
consequences of the fact that you really
can't just turn the global economy on
and off again like a blow heater it's
going to have all of these knock-on
impacts and we're still feeling them
even now it's so interesting following
this row with the airlines and with
heathrow i don't know if you um read
emirates statement on the situation in
heathrow and that cap yeah dawn you've
seen it right just a few keys i've never
i don't think i've actually ever read a
press statement that is so
scathing um this is emirates about
heathrow and that cap ensuring ground
readiness to handle and turn around a
wide-body long-haul aircraft with 500
passengers on board obviously they're
talking about those huge 380 planes yeah
that one no no that hasn't got four
engines but the big one with the four
engines the double decker plane right
they're saying it's impossible it's not
as simple as finding a parking spot at a
mall
and emirates have been really scathing
about heathrow himself saying they chose
not to act not to plan not to invest and
now faced with an armageddon situation
due to their incompetence and non-action
they're pushing the entire burden to
airlines and travelers john what do you
think is this bad planning on heathrow's
part or is this just a knock-on effect
of everything that we've been through in
the last two years
i i well i think it's i think there's
part of both of those involved but i
thought emirates statement was
incredibly refreshing kimberly because
they were being honest i mean emirates
during the pandemic obviously
handled ran their business well so many
airlines british airways being one i
have to say
didn't i mean they made staff redundant
they they didn't re-employ them i mean
we knew that once the pandemic was over
we were allowed to travel again that
this would happen and every one of us
could see it coming kimberly so why
couldn't
heathrow i'm naming heathrow because
that's what we're talking about but
other airports are also suffering it's
not just in this country other other
countries are suffering as well so why
didn't they prepare for this so i
thought emory's statement was incorrect
you know we've run our business well we
can fly we can take off we can get our
passengers where they need to go with
their luggage if that's a shock
why why are you not ready for this it's
so you know fair play to emirates and
heathrow really really are letting so
many people down and kimberly we all
need a holiday and so many families now
haven't been away for two years
desperate to get away ironically for the
weather um and they can't and they're
facing all this stress and trauma it's
interesting emerald saying they're just
going to carry on flying so we'll see
how that plays out in the next couple of
days couple of weeks um let's have a
look at the daily mail tom this is
something you've picked out
this
row around penny mordent and her stance
on trans writes um
yeah what do you think about it do you
think it really has cut through because
you ask people do you think this is what
they're worried about or is it cost of
living top of the agenda for them
of course it is but i think the reason
that this issue is being focused on is
not because it's just cultural or throth
and it's not just because this is kind
of black ops against penny morden's
campaign that she's painted it in some
of the other papers this morning it's
because this gets to some fundamental
questions one of which is the question
of biological reality i fundamentally
think if you refuse to understand that
biological sex is real and it's an
important thing despite the fact that of
course trans people deserve all the
rights and respects in the world then
you really shouldn't be prime minister
um and the other thing that this gets to
is the fact that penny morden has been
slightly
not straightforward with her own
position on this issue so she said trans
women are women at the dispatch box
she has been accused of trying to
resist using words like women and mother
in legislation that was used to allow
sweller brave men to go on maternity
leave and being a supporter of gender
self-id the idea that you could gain
access essentially to many women's
spaces and services just by basis of
self-declaration
she is saying that people have
fundamentally misunderstood her position
that this is a misrepresentation so
you're left with basically two
conclusions neither of which are good
one of which is that she's being
dishonest about what it is that she
actually believes or believes previously
or that she just goes whichever way the
wind is blowing and i think whilst these
issues
fundamentally matter to questions of
sex-based rights but they also speak to
a question of integrity and truthfulness
and that's why they're not going away
it's not because it's just people trying
to stir up a culture or we should be
talking about more serious issues now
she of course insists that she hasn't
changed her position
dawn let's keep stick with the debate
bring up the daily mail they've got the
spread page 12 and 13 on it um what
what did you think who came up on top
who came out on bottom on the bottom who
how did they do do you think well it was
it was absolutely fascinating wasn't it
i mean the frustrating thing kimberly is
that the vast majority of us watching
this have no say over who actually wins
this race um and you know only obviously
only conservative party members can
actually vote on this and the vast
majority of the population aren't i
think it's about i don't know how many
there are actually it's quite difficult
to find out however i mean you know you
know the male is there saying that you
know there was no clear winner i mean i
i personally think that um tom tubman
hat
won
on the performance alone i mean whether
he is experienced enough or well known
enough to become the ultimate leader but
i thought he was quite impressive last
night he shared a sense of humor he
seemed to be saying the right things he
was quite down to earth obviously he
served in the military you know he
praised the nhs for saving um and his
military colleagues when they came back
from afghanistan and iraq so and he made
it a joke with with someone who worked
for the nhs about you know and also
thank you for giving me my children not
you personally and that got a laugh from
the audience i think it was quite good i
thought ah yeah me personally i i
thought liz trust was quite wooden um
and the one thing
i know this sounds really shallow but
liz trust was dressed exactly how
margaret that she used to dress as well
with the [ __ ]
[ __ ] bow blouse is that what they're
called um and so i thought she came
across as wooden and i thought maybe
that um rishi sunak i mean i know this
is going very shallow kimberly but why
wasn't you wearing a tie
i'm sorry i don't want you casually on
that okay we're gonna have to leave it
there tom we want to hear what you think
about the debate so next hour we'll ask
you but we've got to take a break now
and tom will see you in an hour thanks
both
still to come here on sky news breakfast
temperatures rise and the uk prepares to
enter a state of national emergency
[Music]